the notion of giving back is so powerful
I mean I always say the best way to get
something is to give something first
right so I know that you want to auction
off this yeah so you ready to go yeah
but I'm gonna also step up because I
think that you know I know that you want
to start it at up what's the word
hundred quid or hundred quid yeah so
this is what you're getting you getting
an exclusive canvas which is a jab jab
jab right hook canvas it will be signed
and personalized to you during the book
signing and you will also get five books
that go along with it that you can get
signed and personalize these five books
are unsigned cyngor than personal life
in addition whoever wins this I will
give you one full hour over Skype to do
consulting questions pitch me your
business whatever the [ __ ] you want you
want to sing together but understanding
like to me you would be I mean some of
you went to the jab jab jab right hook
website and know how much I'm selling
one hour of my time and what I charge
for it so to me to try to help give more
back I'll offer that as well so I'll let
you go for it thank you so much DJ man
what's the currency called we are
starting a bidding all right do I hear a
hundred pounds raise your hand red 200
200 300 300 400 400 500 500 600 600 700
700 800 pounds - I hear 800 pounds
800 pounds let's clap it up for the
beautiful gentlemen
so we're here 900 pounds 900 pen Wow
1,000 pounds 1,000 pounds slap it up for
this beautiful looking man it feels so
nice
write the check will be written directly
to Great Ormond Street Hospital we're
gonna give the money straight say it
again for everybody at surgeon the full
name of it is Great Ormond Street
Hospital yeah fantastic
one thousand pounds do I hear $1,100
here in the corner 1,200 do I hear 12
hundred pounds twelve hundred houses
gentlemen let's clap that up thirteen
hundred pounds thirteen hundred pounds
Wow
it started because I'm sorry to get
excited I was born on November 14th 14
is a very lucky number for me so I hear
1,400 pounds I like a [ __ ] snake he's
been sitting there watching struck like
a Cobra I love it 1,400 pounds thank you
so much - I hear 1500 pounds 1500 pounds
this is so much it was a couple of
people going for 1,500 1,600 pounds -
why are 1,600 pounds 1,600 pounds let's
clap it up very nice
keep going bro 1,700 pounds
do I hear 1700 pounds Wow are you
believable new player involves 1700
pounds please send up sir that's very
nice yeah okay do I hear 1800 pounds
1800 pounds let me just paint you a
little story let me give you the story
of Zula Korg which was a company they
got an hour of my time and went from
$20,000 a month revenue to $400,000 a
month revenue in one year because of one
hour just painting a picture you also
get the outro music for when everyone is
leaving the first record that we play is
gonna be dedicated to about 25,000
friendship huh that was amazing 2,100
2,100 from the crowd
2,100 lucky 21 21 Wow hand
$2,100 thank you so much sir pounds
Sorry Sorry American Bluff I apologize
that was awesome she get that on camera
um do I hear 2200 2200 2200
oh my goodness Gary 22 hundreds of
German down here thank you so much 2300
Serna back 2,300 thank you 2,400 sir yes
2500 sir yes 2,600 sir yes 2,700 sir
yes 2,800 sir yes 2,900 sir yes 3,000
sir yes yes 3,200 sir what do you say
3150 I love it I love negotiators 3230
250 sir 3,300 sir
yes 3350 sir 3400 sir
3,500 sir we got polices the big that's
just kidding
3450 sir
3,500 thank you very much 3550 sir yes
yes both of you for 3500 two hours of my
time you'll have to fight for the canvas
let's clap it up for these two gentlemen
that's incredible it's very generous of
you friend
you know what we will do gay because
we've only got one canvas it's one of
the posters we will we will get framed
and we'll make sure it's a nice frame
not a 10 pound IKEA one and then the
second no no shots IKEA and we'll make
sure that's the scent for the gentleman
surgery we can arrange that right all
right so now everyone W one unique frame
sign poster and one canvas so make sure
that both gonna get the value friends
thank you so much for having me
I enjoy this tremendously the fact that
we're all now going to heaven makes me
very happy as well
and I enjoyed tonight quite a bit and I
wish you all very healthy holiday and
thank you for being here